What I want to do
in this video is
give an overview of how money
is created in most market based
economies, and even a little
bit of a discussion of what
really is money.
And we can go into much
more depth in future videos.
And I think in many
videos I already
have gone into a much
more technical depth.
In most market based
economies right now
there is a central bank, which
is essentially the actor,
they do many things.
They often will be a
regulatory agency as well.
But their main role is to
have the right to print money,
and to put that money
into circulation.
And I'll rely heavily
on the model of the US.
That's hard to read.
The central bank
in some countries
is formerly part
of the government.
In other countries,
it's pseudo-independent.
In the US.
It's more of the
pseudo-independent flavor
of a central bank, although
obviously closely connected
with the government.
The US Federal Reserve,
a lot of the leaders
are appointed by the government.
It's excess profits go
back to the government.
And so obviously it has very
close ties to the government.
But when the central bank
decides to print money,
it literally can just create it.
It could literally
print physical money.
Or it can create
electronic money,
which has the same exact effect.
So let's say the central
bank, it goes out there
and it goes out there
and it prints three--
and we'll just focus on
the physical right now.
It's a little bit
easier to conceptualize.
And it just goes out there and
it prints three physical dollar
bills.
Now it has to figure
out, how does it
get it into circulation?
How does it get it
into the economy?
And it does not just
put it into a helicopter
and drop it from
that helicopter.
Sometimes, in certain
circumstances,
it can lend to this directly to
banks, certain types of banks,
member banks.
But the typical way that
this enters circulation
is that the central bank will
use this newly created money,
this newly created
reserves I should say,
to go out into the open
market and buy securities.
And they typically buy very
safe securities, typically
government debt.
So they will go
out there and they
will put this into circulation.
And in exchange they
are buying securities
from the open market.
So then these securities
from the open market
will go to the central bank.
So these are securities, or
maybe we could call them bonds.
And once they do that, then
whoever had these before,
whoever was the owner of
the securities before,
they just sold them.
Now they have
these dollar bills.
And they could either directly
spend those dollar bills
or they could deposit those
dollar bills in a bank.
If they spend the
dollar bills, then
whoever they gave those
dollar bills to at some point
would want to
deposit it in a bank.
Some way, by buying
these securities,
someone now has
these dollar bills.
And they will deposit
them in a private bank.
So let's draw that.
So right over here
is a private bank.
And now it has the dollar bills.
It has these reserves now.
It has the reserves.
Now, that's not the
end of the story.
This money can now be lent.
And this is key,
because this is what's
typical in most
market economies where
they have fractional
reserve lending.
So fractional reserve lending,
which is a bit strange,
because you are telling the
person who just deposited
this money right here, that
you can go at any time and you
can take this money out.
We've got this money for you.
You can trust us.
You don't have to be
paranoid about what's
going on with this money.
But the reality
is that this bank
is allowed to keep only a
fraction of these reserves,
and lend to the rest of it out.
In order for this system
to not be super fragile,
the Central Bank then
also insures these banks.
But we'll talk about
that into more depth.
But here.
I just want to show you
how the money is created
in this fractional
reserve lending system.
So this bank right
over here says,
well I have to keep a
little bit of these reserves
in case that guy comes.
The probability of
all my customers
coming on the same day and
asking for all of their money
is low.
I just have to keep a little
bit for whoever does come.
And then the rest of
it I can lend out,
even though I promised everyone
that all of their money
is available.
And so they lend
it out to whoever
needs to borrow that money,
who looks like a decent risk.
And those people might
not spend it immediately.
And so they would
deposit it into a bank.
Or they might spend
that money immediately.
They by a factor,
or they buy a car.
They do something with it.
And whoever they bought
that new thing from,
those people now have
the money and they
will deposit it into a bank.
And so this newly
lent money will then
end up in perhaps another bank.
It could even be the same bank.
So that will also end up
in a bank, right over here.
And now this bank,
it can also only keep
a fraction of the reserves
and lend out the rest.
And for simplicity, in
most banking systems,
they only have to keep
on the order of about 10%
of the reserves in house, and
the rest they could lend out.
But over here.
I'm keeping much
larger reserves just
for the sake of making it
easy to draw this diagram.
So this bank right
over here, maybe it
decides to keep
this dollar bill,
and it could lend this
one right over here out.
And once again, when it
lands that dollar bill,
it will end up
somehow-- the person
they lend it to might keep
it in a bank temporarily.
Or they might immediately
buy something.
And when they buy something,
it will eventually
end up in a bank because the
person they bought something
from will deposit that money.
And so it could end
up in another bank.
And now this is interesting,
and in future videos
we'll go into more of the math
of exactly how much money is
being created.
And it's an interesting
mathematical problem.
Actually, it's a sum of an
infinite series, and all that.
And you can look
that up if you're
interested in those ideas.
But the basic idea here is even
though the central bank printed
three units of base money,
$3.00 right over here,
there's a lot more
money in the system.
You have this guy, who made this
deposit, thinks he has $3.00.
This person thinks
they have $2.00.
they have one.
So just in this example over
here, we have one, two, three,
four, five $6.00.
So just right over here we
have $6.00 in this system.
And you might say, well,
is this really money?
This is deposited.
This guy thinks he has
it, but he's not using it.
If he had to use it he
would have to withdraw it,
and then the bank wouldn't
be able to do this.
And this is where checking
accounts are really important.
I'm assuming that these were
on demand checking accounts.
So this guy, the
reason why he's not
going to withdraw this
money, is he can still
use it as money
by writing checks.
So if this guy, let's say this
is all the money that he has,
and he decides if he really
needs to buy an apple.
And that Apple costs $1.00.
So this is my drawing of
an apple right over here.
He does not have to withdraw
this $1.00 out of the bank.
He can write a check.
So right now he has claims to
all three of these dollars.
He can write a check to
the apple vendor, so $1.00.
He writes a check, gives
it to the apple vendor,
and now he'll get the apple, so
this check is acting as money.
And now the apple vendor
will have the rights to one
of these dollars
right over here.
And now the apple vendor
could write a check.
So this dollar never has to
leave the banking system.
But because of checks
it is essentially
enabling-- this check writing--
is enabling these transactions
to occur.
So it's still
enabling, either you
could view it as it's still
acting in some forms of money
because the rights
to it can change,
even though it's sitting out
in here and it's been lent.
Or you could say that it's
enabling the writing of checks
that are acting as
some form of money.
And the whole reason
I want to do this,
I'm going through
this exercise, is
to show you that the amount
of money in circulation
isn't really in
the Central Banks,
or not directly in the
Central Bank's control.
They can definitely decide,
hey I'm going to print money,
buy securities, put
it into circulation.
Or if they want to take
money out of circulation,
they can decide to
sell these securities.
And then when they
sell the securities,
maybe this guy will
buy them, those dollars
will go back to
the Central Bank.
And maybe they could put
it out of commission.
But you have this whole
effect right over here.
If you have more
lending occurring,
if the banks are feeling very
confident, then more of this
will happen.
You will get more of this--
the multiplier effect
of this lending.
And if less lending
is happening,
then you could potentially
see all of this contract.